class switching or isotype switching is
a recombination process by which
different isotypes are generated from
the default IGM antibody
naive B cells has by default IGM or igd
on their surface
but once T Cell activates the B cell it
would eventually be converted into a
activated B cell and differentiate into
a plasma cell that plasma cell can
secrete IGM IG a IGG Etc and this is
happening via the process of class
switching class switching is triggered
by specific regions known as switch
regions shown in red and the key enzyme
in this process is activity induced
diamines in a sequential process the
constant region of the antibody Gene
would be recombined out and this would
produce a desired isotype without
pathogen encounter isotype switching
doesn't happen it's irreversible and it
changes the DNA and it is influenced by
cytokines